يجب ان اشير الى ما نشاهده الان من صور
هذه الصور تاتينا من اليونان وتحديدا من
اثينا مشاهدينا وفيها خروج
لبعض المتظاهرين تجمع لمجموعه من الاشخاص
في همم رساله تضامن مع الاكراد في باريس
وطبعا الاحتجاجات الكرديه التي شاهدناها
في باريس صور مباشره من اليونان كنا نتحدث
قبل قليل 2013 كان هناك تضامن من اكثر همم
من جهه خروج لتظاهرات همم دائما للاكراد
في اكثر من بلد وها نحن الان وكاننا نعيد
المشهد من جديد وهمم من قلب باريس الى
مارسيليا والان نتوجه الى اثنا في اليونان
حيث خروج لعدد من المتظاهرين تضامنا مع
الاكراد بعد حادثه اليوم التي قتل فيها
ثلاثه اشخاص من الاكراد في عمليه قتل همم
واطلاق نار عشوائي من قبل مشتبه به كان قد
قام العام الماضي فقط بعمليه اخرى مشابهه
ولكن باستخدام السلاح همم الابيض